TYRA: Previously
on America's Next Top Model,
the girls hit the streets
of Sydney, Australia,
to work their interview skills.
What do you think
major fashion faux pas are?
WOMAN: Women wearing tops
where their bra straps
are showing.
Oh, no.
TYRA: The Cover Girl commercial
was a breeze for some.
Now that's easy breezy,
beautiful Cover Girl.
TYRA: But for Jael and Brittany,
it was a disaster.
I wish...blah.
Take 23.
Well, illuminate...
TYRA: Jael failed to sell
her commercial side
and she was sent home.
Five girls remain,
Renee, Jaslene,
Dionne, Natasha,
and Brittany.
Who will be eliminated tonight?
( music playing )
You wanna be on top?
WOMAN: ♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ It's time to make it hot ♪
♪ You know,
that we don't stop ♪
♪ And when you get it hot ♪
♪ You got to be on top ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
( music playing )
NATASHA:
I'm so glad that we made it
to the final five.
Oh, my God.
I cannot believe this.
JASLENE: Natasha,
you're too much.
NATASHA: I know. Oh, my God.
This is, like, too much.
Like too much.
Brittany used
her short-term memory
as a crutch in panel.
I just had
a really hard time with it
because of my short-term memory.
RENEE: I feel like it was unfair
that Jael goes home.
I have a feeling now
it's just gonna get
really cutthroat
and really serious.
NATASHA: It sucks
to see Jael go home,
but Jael knew
she was going home,
because I seem to be doing
a lot better
at the photo shoots.
( music playing )
WOMAN: A Tyra Mail?
No, but we have Jael mail.
Jael left letters
for each of us girls.
"You are the most beautiful girl
I have ever seen.
Love, Jael."
"When you win, will you loan me
a thousand dollars
to pay my rent?"
"If you'd gotten cut, you know
I would've sacrificed
myself for you."
DIONNE: I really
wanted Brittany to go home,
because when we did that skit,
Brittany was
all excited about acting.
There's traffic
all up and down 5th Avenue.
DIONNE: She knew every line
word-for-word,
but when it came down
to this commercial...
I just had
a really hard time with it
because of my short-term memory.
DIONNE: Short-term memory?
You are lying.
She always makes up an excuse
for every single thing.
( music playing )
BRITTANY: We got Tyra Mail.
All right. It says,
"There's more to go see
than kangaroos and koalas.
Love, Tyra."
ALL: Go-see.
( music playing )
Hey.
PRISCILLA: Hi, girls.
I'm Priscilla,
and this Jodhi.
Welcome to Priscilla's
Model Management.
At Priscilla's, we represent
some of Australia's
most successful models.
Now, Jodhi has been
a top model with me
for the past 15 years.
And she is also about
to host Series 3
of Australia's Next Top Model.
Okay, girls.
Well, today is go-see day.
You are going to go and meet
different designers
who represent
very different areas in fashion.
This is where Jodhi's going
to really be able
to help you out.
Yeah, it's really important
to be a chameleon
and make it really easy for them
to see you selling
their product,
to just really understand
your audience,
who you're trying to sell to.
PRISCILLA: Now, the designers
are going to be judging you
on your personality,
your portfolio,
and also on runway.
And at the end of the day,
the girl who makes
the best impression
on the designers
will win the challenge.
Now, you must be back here
by 4:30.
Anybody who comes here
after 4:30
will be disqualified.
We'll see you back here
at the end of the day.
( music playing )
DIONNE: We have a map,
the names of the designers,
their dresses,
and time is ticking.
13 Cook Road.
( music playing )
- I'm Anna.
- Jaslene.
- Nice to meet you.
JASLENE: My strategy is to be
calm, cool, and collective.
ANNA: You'd have
a great runway body.
I'd like you to try on a bikini.
Jaslene had a great body,
she held herself really well
in her walk.
So she'd be great.
- What is your name?
- Natasha.
- Natasha?
- Natasha from Russia.
- Yes.
- NATASHA: I'm very sexy,
and I'm using everything
I learned
to bring a lot of energy
to the designers.
- WAYNE: Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, too.
( music playing )
WAYNE: Renee, photographically
maybe needed
a little bit more work,
but I would definitely book her
in a show.
I'm pushing the button,
I don't see anything happening.
13 Cook Road.
( bell dinging )
- This is Cook Road, right?
- Yup.
I don't get it.
I'm so confused.
DIONNE: I see you guys
have a lot of swimwear.
ANNA: Yeah.
Dionne has a really
strong personality,
which I think is great.
She's very confident
and bubbly.
DIONNE:
I'm going to go get changed now,
but I want to keep it.
I was like, "Can I keep this?"
You know, I'm trying to see
what they were going to say.
Oh, thank you so much.
I got a chance
to keep the swimsuit.
RENEE: We need to go to 119.
( bell dings )
- BRITTANY: Hi.
- Hello.
( music playing )
BRITTANY: I think
I have a little bit trouble
with my walk at some point.
TINA: Brittany needs a lot
of work with her runway walk,
so I would not book Brittany
for a show.
Hope the rest
of your stay is pleasant.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
( music playing )
BRITTANY: I guess
there's a lot of pressure,
but I don't really feel it.
I mean, one designer
doesn't like you,
it's not the end of the world.
( music playing )
I like it when you're softer.
She does have a tendency
to look a little hard-edged,
but I think Renee
would have a good future
in modeling.
How tall are you,
5'9"-ish, 5'9" 1/2?
Hello?
I love this.
Go-sees are actually fun.
You go and try
on different clothes.
I love this outfit,
can I keep it?
Can I keep it?
You can keep the top.
I'm in shopping heaven.
( music playing )
Two, two, two, two, two, two.
Two. Not one, two.
Oh, three.
Why isn't it going up?
There we go.
( crickets chirping )
This is level three.
All right.
( music playing )
RENEE: Before my go-see
with Kit Willow,
I hear that
she's just had a baby,
so I sneak
a couple pictures of my son
into my portfolio.
Aw, who's this?
RENEE: That's my son.
I've got a baby girl.
Oh, really? Congratulations.
Thank you.
- Hello.
- Hi. How are you?
BRITTANY: I'm all right
with the small talk thing,
but you don't want to do
too much small talk
because it is
a professional setting.
You're not there to chitchat.
( music playing )
You're enjoying Sydney?
Yes, I love it here.
That's great.
( music playing )
- ALICE: Fantastic.
- Thank you.
ALICE: You got
a really good walk,
nice and strong,
but not too over the top.
- It's a winner.
- All right.
( music playing )
WAYNE: Keep your arms
under control.
Very uncoordinated.
Her whole brain
is trying to work out
how to catwalk.
It didn't come naturally.
- DIONNE: I'm Dionne.
- Hi, Dionne.
DIONNE: Nice to meet you.
My third go-see
was Kit Willow.
When I walked in the room,
I see this dog on the floor.
KIT: Shoulders back,
I feel like your shoulders
are a little bit rounded.
Dionne's posture
wasn't fantastic.
DIONNE: These are awesome.
( music playing )
ARABELLA: That's good.
Got a good walk.
RENEE: Thank you.
- Is it hot?
- I love a bit
of black on black.
When I saw Dionne, I thought,
lots of confidence.
Definitely
I'd put her in a show.
I thought I was going to see
that hanging out
of the back of your pocket
on the way out.
( giggling )
( music playing )
Can I tuck the skirt?
ARABELLA: I thought Jaslene
was very young
and fresh,
which I really liked.
( music playing )
ARABELLA: Natasha was sexual
and flirtatious.
Something I would not go for.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to me you, too.
( needle scratches record )
DIONNE: I have an hour left,
so I have one more,
and then I'm going to go back
to Priscilla's.
ANNA:
Renee had really great legs
and a great body for swimwear.
RENEE: Can we go
to Priscilla's Model Management?
DIONNE: We're just going
to head back to Priscilla's.
I don't want to be disqualified.
BRITTANY: How long is it going
to take to get back
to Challis Avenue?
Fifteen minutes,
ten to fifteen minutes.
BRITTANY: Okay. So I'm
going to go over to Cooper.
Okay.
( music playing )
Excuse me, do you know
where number 25
is on this street?
No, I don't.
Okay, thanks.
That's not right.
I should've jumped
in the cab.
( music playing )
I need to get back
for real.
Okay. Back to Priscilla's.
RENEE: Thank you very much, sir.
I was the first one back
to Priscilla's agency,
because if you don't make it
back by 4:30,
you are disqualified.
Shut that door and lock it.
DIONNE: Hell, yeah.
Try to go
as fast as you can.
BRITTANY: Sorry,
I'm on such a time schedule.
I realized
I was almost out of time,
so I saw her
as quickly as possible.
Hopefully at least
get Brownie points for that.
Okay. My cab driver obviously
didn't come over here
like I asked him to.
I see that the taxi's
not there,
I'm like, "Oh, ( ... )"
( music playing )
I asked my cab driver
to meet over on Cooper Street,
and he obviously
didn't listen.
- MAN: Hey.
- BRITTANY: I asked you
to meet me on Cooper Street.
So I'm going
to go over to Cooper.
Okay.
( music playing )
I ( ... ) believe this.
NATASHA: My strategy is to see
as many designers as possible,
but it's really,
really important
to be on time.
Are we almost there?
MAN: One minute.
JASLENE: I went to go see
the last designer,
which I shouldn't have,
because I cannot fail
this challenge.
We're here, right?
Is this it?
RENEE: Who's that?
Oh, here runs Jaslene.
- JASLENE: Aah!
- RENEE: One minute,
one minute.
Yes!
I make it back to Priscilla's
a minute before.
I'm like, "Where's Natasha,
where's Brittany?"
We have two slackers.
JASLENE: Is it 4:30?
Once that thing hits the 12.
Four...
- RENEE: Three...
- two...
one.
DIONNE: 4:30.
RENEE: Congratulations.
JASLENE: These girls
are late, late, late
for something
that's very, very important.
JASLENE: Look at her running
for nothing.
Run, girl.
- Hi, girls.
- ALL: Hi.
PRISCILLA: Well,
congratulations to you.
It's 4:30, and you've made it
back on time.
- Yes.
- RENEE: Don't yes.
- You missed it.
- No, I did not.
PRISCILLA: It's so important
to be on time.
Even if you're a minute late,
the designers
don't want to see you,
and consequently
you're disqualified
from the challenge.
Could you please wait
outside now?
- NATASHA: Yeah, sure.
- PRISCILLA: Thanks.
I know that
if I wouldn't be disqualified,
I would win the challenge,
because I definitely
would book more jobs
than any of those girls.
Congratulations, you three.
You've really shown
that you're true professionals
and you know the importance
of being on time.
( music playing )
BRITTANY: I was late
for 30 seconds.
I asked my ( ... ) cab driver
to meet me on Cooper Street,
and he didn't show up.
I made it to five.
I had a cab driver
that didn't know how to drive.
- NATASHA: It's okay.
- It's not okay!
It sucks because it's not
my ( ... ) fault!
It's his, 'cause I asked him
to meet over there!
Um...
I just want to tell you that
some people have war
in their countries.
BRITTANY:
I can be upset right now,
'cause I'm really pissed off.
DIONNE: When Priscilla comes in
to announce
who won the challenge,
Brittany is cursing
and just going off,
and you could actually see
the expression
on Priscilla's face like,
"Who's that out there
yappin' at the mouth?"
BRITTANY: He's not driving slow!
I asked him to meet me there,
and it took me two minutes
to ( ... ) run back,
and I would have made it.
NATASHA: Don't be--
Please, don't be...
BRITTANY: Stop telling me
not to be upset!
I can be upset if want to.
I had a cab driver
that just was not good.
PRISCILLA: I assume
that Brittany knows
that she's been disqualified
as she hasn't come
into the room.
But anyway, girls,
I've now got the comments
that the designers have made.
Renee, the designers thought
you had a great personality,
but they felt
that you photograph
too hard at times.
Dionne,
your personality appealed
to the designers,
but you need to work
on your posture.
Jaslene, you have a great body,
they loved your walk,
and overall you got
the best feedback
in this challenge,
so congratulations.
I won?
Oh, my God!
- You got it.
- I won a challenge!
Oh, my God. Girls,
I have not won a challenge.
- Oh, my God.
- How exciting.
We're so excited for you,
and Jodhi's now going
to tell you
what you're going to win.
To spice up your portfolio,
they've booked an incredible
photo shoot for you
on top of the world,
on Australia's
very famous
Sydney Harbor Bridge.
So you must pick a friend.
Dionne.
PRISCILLA: Congratulations.
All of you have done
a terrific job today.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
PRISCILLA: See you later.
Bye-bye.
NATASHA: Can I hug the winner?
You're the winner?
Come here.
BRITTANY: I asked my cab driver
to meet me on the street,
like, two streets over.
So because my guy
didn't listen and said okay,
I got ( ... )
JASLENE: Brittany,
why do you put up this excuses
and make yourself look bad?
She just has some excuse
all the time.
I missed it by a minute.
RENEE: No,
because she showed up at 4:31.
She was just one minute late.
( music playing )
JASLENE: Dionne and I arrive
at the Sydney Harbor Bridge,
climbing the stairs,
and we're, like, 440 feet high.
We're scared,
but we're, like, also amazed
by the view that we got.
And we just see
the whole Sydney,
and it looks amazing.
Finally getting towards the top,
we see Nigel standing up there
with his camera.
Oh, my God. Is that Nigel?
- Congratulations, guys.
- Thank you.
- Thanks, Nigel.
- Welcome to the top
of the world,
pretty much, right?
So we're going to have some fun
up here today, all right?
We're like, "Okay, that's it,
like, the party's started."
( music playing )
NIGEL: That's nice,
just like that.
( music playing )
Dionne, come round,
- both sides, like that.
- DIONNE: We had a great time
up there on that bridge.
I think Nigel
had a lot of fun with us.
Looks great.
( music playing )
JASLENE: This is the second time
that Nigel shoots us,
so it was just like
plus, plus, plus for us.
( music playing )
NATASHA: Hmm,
home sweet home.
- RENEE: Tyra Mail.
- DIONNE: Tyra Mail.
"Men are from Mars,
but women are from Venus.
Can you rock each planet?
half of your picture
perfect future
is in my hands."
- What?
- JASLENE: What?
DIONNE: It may have something
to do with, you know,
like, aliens or something,
because it says "future."
( music playing )
DIONNE: "Can you rock
each planet?"
"Can you rock each planet?"
DIONNE: We were so thrown
by the Tyra Mail,
we actually sat there
for, like, 30 minutes
trying to figure out
what this Tyra Mail meant.
"Can you rock each planet?"
NATASHA: "Can you rock
each planet?"
"Can you rock each planet?"
Okay. "Can you rock
each planet?"
It's like--
We couldn't figure it out.
Maybe we're just, like,
reading two parts.
JASLENE: Yes! "In my hands!"
She has the camera.
So Tyra's
the photographer tomorrow?
DIONNE: Yeah.
RENEE: I'm very nervous
to take a photo with Tyra.
You know,
you want to impress her
with what you've learned,
and she's also a judge.
She's also the judge.
( music playing )
Well, let me tell you
good morning.
- ALL: Good morning.
- JAY: It's early, right?
- DIONNE: Yes.
- So we're actually doing
two very different shoots today.
We're doing one,
a picture that would appear
in a woman's magazine,
and we're going to do
a totally different shoot,
something that would appear
in a men's magazine.
So I got a photographer
who knows all about women,
is really sensitive to women.
She's going to come out here
and start shooting
you guys first.
Could we bring out
our photographer
for this morning?
( music playing )
- Oh, my God!
- We knew it was you!
- TYRA: You knew it was me?
- ALL: Yes.
How?
RENEE: Your Tyra Mail.
I'm very excited to see Tyra.
I'm excited to have her on set
and see how we work.
And, remember,
Tyra is
an experienced photographer
who shot the girls
on America's Next Top Model
in the past.
All right.
Now, I don't want to see you
looking like Playboy
with me, right?
It's got to be soft
and beautiful
and fashion.
And with our male photographer,
you could do all that...
( laughter )
- All right.
- JAY: Oh, wait,
we got one little thing that
I saved for you to tell them.
They're shooting
in bathing suits,
and what else
are they shooting with?
Sexy men.
- No way.
- Yes.
This is the most beautiful light
of the entire day.
So that's why models wake up
at the crack of dawn.
Are you all ready to be shot?
ALL: Yes.
Could you help me get
this other earring in?
SUTAN: It's always something
with you, huh?
BRITTANY: Christian comes in,
and he's giving
all the girls extensions.
It doesn't bother me
as long as it's not sewn in.
TYRA: How are you,
Miss Brittany?
- I'm good, how are you?
- TYRA: Good.
You ready?
Okay. Remember,
you're selling to the chicks.
Nice.
What are you feeling?
- A little cold.
- TYRA: A little cold?
- But it's okay.
- TYRA: Yeah.
Out a little bit
on the field on the left.
Out on this field.
A little more exaggeration
with your back.
There you go.
And also Brittany,
you don't have to be afraid
of your sexuality.
There you go.
You don't want to be outshined
by this boy.
Closer, closer, almost kissing,
closer, closer, closer.
Nice.
Thank you.
Brittany seemed
a little bit nervous,
and she seemed like
she was holding back a bit,
but there is still something
from inside her eyes
that's just kind
of spellbinding.
She has that thing.
( music playing )
All right, Dionne.
Relax your face. Not mean, soft.
Ready, and...
Could you put this arm backwards
around his head?
DIONNE: Having Tyra
be the director
and the photographer today,
it made me feel more comfortable
than what I usually am.
TYRA: I used to hate it
when I would be working
and the photographer
would say, "Okay.
Now, lay down in the sand."
I go, "Okay."
( laughs )
TYRA: Chin up.
Slightly away from me though.
Turn away so I don't see inside
your nostrils.
Relax your shoulders.
Not so posed with the arm.
That's too much.
You tend to get a little
too mean in your eyebrows,
and your face
is already intense and strong,
so you don't have to go.
I think Dionne's
concentration is off.
I would tell her, "Arms back,"
and she'd do that,
and then right
when I'd pick the camera,
she'd go.
She constantly
had to be directed.
It was a little frustrating
for me.
And I think she's going
to have a nice shot,
an amazing shot?
I don't think that happened.
TYRA: Jaslene.
Tyra.
Are you ready?
Are you sure?
If you guys can find a rock
and stand on it together.
I don't care which one.
Actually, that's a safe one
right there.
Nice.
Need a little bit more
exaggeration.
Even though
it's a women's magazine,
we don't want it to look
like wedding shots.
I was slightly disappointed
in Jaslene
with me being
her photographer today.
I want to feel
the certain connection
that I can kind
of pick up her vibe,
and I didn't pick up anything.
You guys
are not working together.
I need to feel that you guys
are feeling each other.
JASLENE: I'm sitting there
concentrating about,
"How am I going to do this,
Jaslene?"
Then that's when I got,
"Okay, Jaslene,
just let it go,
don't be so tense."
TYRA: Nice. I love the pride.
Gorgeous. Yeah.
JASLENE: How do you like
the hand, Tyra?
TYRA: That's nice.
Nice.
Give me a little bit
more creative editorial poses.
Lean forward,
give me some profiles.
There you go.
Got it. Thank you.
It got magical
toward the end.
- That was good.
- JASLENE: Oh, thank you.
- You did good.
- JASLENE: Thank you so much.
( music playing )
TYRA: Are you ready
to get soaking wet?
RENEE: Are we getting
in the water?
Yeah.
RENEE: It is freezing,
and I get in that water.
- I am so cold.
- We're going to go fast.
We're going to get you
out of here.
RENEE: It's all right.
- Oh.
- TYRA: There you go.
Aim that bounce card
toward her face.
Lean back again.
Look at him,
face him like almost like
you're doing a Spanish dancing.
Oh, good. Gorgeous.
Oh, that is so gorgeous.
You're understanding
this exercise
very well now.
Renee just has a natural thing.
She really, really does.
Final shot.
Great, Renee,
thank you very much.
RENEE: I'm not sure
how I look glamorous
in the freezing cold water,
but Tyra liked it,
and I just tried
to picture myself warm
and in Maui
and 85 and sunny.
That's what I kept saying
to myself.
I made a pee-pee.
I made a pee-pee, Mommy.
- NATASHA: Hi.
- JAY: How are you?
NATASHA: I'm great.
Are you ready to take pictures?
NATASHA: Yes. I'm so happy.
TYRA: I need you
to lay on your back.
I like upside down pictures.
TYRA: I know you do.
You guys look great together.
Really nice.
Can we see your neck?
Mm-hmm.
Little more emotion,
a little more passion.
Just relax your neck.
Natasha is going to have
some nice shots.
She's not going to have
as many to choose from
because of the--
Relax your shoulders a little.
There you go.
Peek at me.
No, losing your neck.
Relax your neck.
Very nice.
That was just gorgeous.
You did model, you did good,
yes, very nice.
- NATASHA: You give me hug?
- Yes.
NATASHA: Tyra's great
as a photographer.
She gives you
so many compliments
that you feel yourself
like a top model.
All right. So now, it's time
to make it more sexy.
I've said it before,
and I'll say it again,
the model
that can have women love her
and men love her, too,
are the most famous models
in the world.
Are you ready for the man?
- ALL: Yeah!
- TYRA: All right!
See you later.
JAY: So Tyra's done.
So we're just
going to finish off
your make up and stuff.
Then you'll meet Michael Omm,
a very famous
Australian photographer,
who'll be taking
your men's magazine photo.
( music playing )
We're bringing sexy back.
MICHAEL: Just relax your eyes.
JAY:
What I love about Jaslene
and our shoot in the afternoon
is she came to set
as she said...
( snapping )
ready.
MICHAEL: That's it. Right there.
JAY: That's beautiful.
My God, that looks hot.
JASLENE:
Hearing Jay compliment me
is exciting.
That was gorgeous.
I know you're cold,
No, you're freezing.
( laughing )
Oh.
I'm in this cold-ass water,
trying to pose,
trying to be sexy,
trying to be seductive.
You know what, Dionne,
it just looks mean.
It doesn't look sexy.
Every time I look at Dionne,
I see a gorgeous girl,
and then she gets in front
of the camera
and just--instead
of giving me sexy,
she gives me mean.
MICHAEL: That's enough.
JAY: You know, those
little smirky smiley ones
almost work for you.
They take the meanness
out of the shot.
A little bit more sex.
JAY: Love that expression.
Finally.
Something soft and pretty.
MICHAEL: Beautiful.
Beautiful. Thank you.
Ready to get down and dirty?
Yeah.
I like doing sexy,
because that is one thing
I know I'm good at.
Grab his hand,
put it on your ass,
and take your hand on it.
JAY: Well, that's great.
MICHAEL: Stay there.
We're getting hot over here.
I need to take my sweater off.
Ooh.
Renee committed to the shot.
It was stunning.
She looked gorgeous.
All right, you two.
No messing around.
I hope that's not how you
are intimate in real life.
- MICHAEL: There.
- JAY: Now you're getting it.
Great.
Now you're getting it.
MICHAEL: Cool.
All right.
JAY: I have never seen
you look that sexual
in a picture before.
So you gave it.
I don't know
if I'd do anything different,
because I did get
the shot off eventually,
and in this competition,
it's all about one shot.
JAY: Now this next one,
she might give us
porn star in a second,
so we got to watch it.
( music playing )
JAY: Whoo. Okay, honey.
There we go.
Every now and then,
the pose was a little awkward,
but I think overall
Natasha got the vibe
that we were going for.
- MICHAEL: Yeah.
- JAY: That's it.
NATASHA: I felt like this was
my best day
out of the whole competition.
MICHAEL: Very good.
JAY: This was good.
- NATASHA: Okay. Thank you.
- JAY: Thanks.
DIONNE: Home sweet
freakin' home.
RENEE: Tyra Mail.
DIONNE: "Tomorrow you will meet
with the judges.
Only four will continue on
in hopes of becoming
America's Next Top Model.
Love, Tyra."
JASLENE: I want to see
Renee go home.
I feel like Renee is here
because she's, like, hungry
for the money,
and she looks old.
I got to eat
and go to sleep.
I have no idea who's gonna go,
I have no idea
who's going to stay...
Ooh.
BRITTANY: The photo shoot
was definitely my opportunity
to kind of, like,
get back in the good graces,
I guess.
I don't think I'm going to be
in the bottom two again,
because I think
I did a damn good job.
( music playing )
TYRA: Well, welcome back
to the judging room.
All right. You guys know
the prizes, right?
The first is a modeling contract
with one
of the top modeling agencies
in the entire world,
Elite Model Management.
A six-page spread
and a cover
of Seventeen Magazine,
and a $100,000 contract
with Cover Girl Cosmetics.
You all know our lovely judges.
The first is Mr. Nigel Barker,
noted fashion photographer.
Miss J. Alexander,
runway diva coach,
extraordinaire.
I hope this is not
your favorite color today.
TYRA: Miss Twiggy,
icon, living legend.
And Priscilla Leighton Clark,
who is the managing director
of Priscilla's Model Management
here in Sydney.
So now it's time
for your individual evaluations,
and the judges will deliberate
and determine which one of you
is going back to the U,
to the S, to the A.
All right. First up is Brittany.
So, Brittany, this week,
you had to go on go-sees,
and I understand yours
didn't end so well.
- No.
- Tell us what happened.
I didn't make it back in time.
I didn't leave enough time
for sort
of extenuating circumstances,
so I made a big mistake.
I asked my ( ... ) cab driver
to meet me on Cooper Street,
and he didn't ( ... ) show up!
You really need to learn
to contain yourself,
because people
don't like the tantrums.
I just worried now,
because I did
so poorly last week,
and sort of frustrated
with myself. That's all.
TYRA: I got word Brittany
that none of the clients said
that they wanted to book you,
not one of them,
which is odd to me,
because you take
some of the strongest
pictures here.
I didn't know that.
TWIGGY: You weren't emotional
on the go-sees, no?
- Not at all, no.
- TWIGGY: I'm absolutely shocked
that you didn't get booked.
TYRA: I think
you're a very good example
of, it's not just
about being pretty
and having pretty pictures,
but there might have been
an energy or something,
or a personality thing
that didn't click
with the designers.
All right. So you had
a couple of photo shoots
this week.
Michael Omm shot
your very sexy man magazine...
- Yes.
- TYRA: ...photo shoot.
And I shot your
soft, sexy female photo shoot.
Now let's see
your best sexy man shot.
( music playing )
- J.: Ooh.
- PRISCILLA: Ooh.
Can we see the close up?
- Oh, yeah.
- TYRA: Oh, yes.
Sookie Sookie.
TWIGGY: The eyes are so strong,
and it's a very sexy picture.
The camera loves you.
That's why you've got to find
this personality
when you do your meetings.
I was very shocked,
because I see
you as the ethereal
kind of angelic girl
with the innocent face
that guys are going to be like,
"I don't get why she's a model."
I mean, you know,
because guys are like so...
- Mm-hmm.
- ...one track
when it comes to what beauty is
and they don't understand
your type of beauty sometimes.
And, um...
but they understand
overt sexuality,
so this shows
that you can do both.
Let's see your best shot
avec moi.
- MICHAEL: Beautiful too.
- TYRA: Mmm.
MICHAEL: You're giving two
completely different looks
at the same time.
They both work.
And if you can do this,
that's what makes a model.
- TYRA: Exactly.
- J.: So no more
model tear droplets.
- BRITTANY: Okay.
- TYRA: Jay said that
for the women's magazine,
your male model outshined you
and you second-guessed
your poses.
Don't let a boy outshine you,
because boys usually
are the accessory in a shot.
I know you were
a male model, Nigel,
but y'all were accessories.
Yeah. Right.
- TYRA: Thank you.
- Thank you.
Up next is Natasha.
Natasha, you, uh,
had an issue
with the go-sees as well.
What was your issue?
I was late.
I felt that you handled it
very well.
You were a bit cross,
but you handled it well.
- Thank you.
- TYRA: All right, Natasha.
So, you had two photo shoots,
one with a male photographer
for a male magazine.
TWIGGY: Wow.
The last few sessions, you're
just excelling. Well done.
TYRA: You know how your lips
get in the way a lot,
and so you go like this
too much?
This is the one time
where you could push them out,
and it's okay.
They're kind of open like,
"Yeah, baby, come on, baby.
Yeah, yeah. Come on to me."
And you also had a photo shoot
where you had to pose
for a women's magazine.
- MICHAEL: Mmm.
- PRISCILLA: I love your look.
You seem to be confident,
which is really nice, you know.
It's nice when somebody
seems to just have it.
You have a sort of a...
almost a Calvin Klein-
esque model look.
TWIGGY: Yes, she does.
TYRA: Natasha,
I enjoyed shooting you.
And you did a really good job,
but your problem is,
Jay and I call it the turtle.
You...
Relax your shoulders
a little, great.
This does not mean sexy,
so just relax it.
All right, thank you, Natasha.
Up next is Jaslene.
So, Jaslene, you did go-sees
and were the challenge winner.
- I won?
- PRISCILLA: Yes, you did.
Oh, my God!
It's about time.
TYRA: Yeah. Your first win.
- Yes.
- All right,
Jaslene, so you had
two photo shoots,
one with a male photographer
for a male magazine.
- PRISCILLA: Wow.
- TYRA: Ooh.
See that eye contact, Jaslene?
That is the eye contact
that men love.
MICHAEL: The amazing thing
about you is even
with half of your face
covered in hair,
you still maintain
a great face shot.
TYRA: All right, Jaslene,
you had a photo shoot
shot by me.
MICHAEL: Very different here,
I like it a lot.
- PRISCILLA: Yeah.
- TYRA: Yeah, it's very soft.
MICHAEL: What is it
that in this picture,
you look like you've got
a perfect body? Angles.
TYRA: Jaslene,
when you first came to the set,
you were quiet, meek.
JASLENE: I was scared, you know,
I was just thinking
about posing at that point,
not even trying
to connect with you.
TWIGGY: You always must connect
with the photographer.
- TYRA: All right, thank you.
- Thank you.
Up next is Dionne.
All right, Dionne.
So you had a photo shoot
for a male magazine.
Too close-up.
J.: For me, it's not one
of your best shoots.
TYRA: In going
through your film, Dionne,
you tend to go
into this mean face,
like a, hmm, hmm!
So you have to learn
to give a softness
with sexy, not a this.
Okay.
Give me three poses right now.
Hit it.
TYRA: Mean. Mean.
- Mean.
- J.: Yeah.
You see with that?
You just did it.
I--I didn't know
until you guys said that.
It's just natural.
( laughs )
Let's see your female shot.
MICHAEL: Okay.
look at the male model.
He looks relax,
he's just looking past you.
There's a serenity,
and then I see your face,
and it's connected
with the camera,
but it looks too, pow.
J.: Is that Nigel with her?
( laughter )
TYRA:
You have to be so directed,
like, every little tiny thing,
so you have to really relax
and listen to the photographer
and feel it.
You want to inspire
the photographer.
TYRA: All right, Dionne.
Thank you.
All right.
Last, but not least, Renee.
All right, Renee.
So you had two photo shoots,
the first
for a male magazine.
- ALL: Ooh.
- PRISCILLA: Wow.
- NIGEL: That's sexy.
- TWIGGY: That's--yeah.
- PRISCILLA: Gorgeous.
- TWIGGY: Your eye contact
with the camera is great.
That's a very "come hither"
photograph," isn't it?
This is a favorite look
of photographers
for male magazines.
It's that look.
Because it makes the reader
think you want them.
TYRA: You did the booty tooch.
The booty
is the new sex accessory.
And you are tooching that back
and that booty to make men
look back there.
Even though
there's not a lot there,
you're still tooching it.
RENEE: I've got
a little ba-donka-donk.
TYRA: You got a little
somethin' somethin'.
Renee you had
a photo shoot with me.
NIGEL: It's like she's doing
flamingo dancing on water.
PRISCILLA:
You look very graceful,
like you know
what to do with your arms
and, you know, some people can--
they can look clumsy,
but that is graceful shot.
- Thank you.
- TYRA: What I like about this
is on your male shot,
you did a booty tooch,
and on the woman shot,
you're doing like
a back-bend kind of thing,
that's sexy,
but in a different type of way.
So it's very good.
Thank you.
TYRA: Now it's time
for the judges to deliberate.
And when I call you back,
I will announce which one of you
will be eliminated.
( music playing )
TYRA: All right, my friends.
It is time to decide
who's going home.
Natasha.
J.: I think she looks
absolutely wonderful.
Love her.
Sexy without even trying.
I think she's got
the whole package.
She's got the personality,
she's sexy,
beautiful look,
and she wants it.
TYRA: I was very impressed
when I shot Natasha.
She was just such a pleasure
coming on the set.
"Tyra, I'm happy to be here."
Brittany.
TWIGGY:
She's incredibly photogenic.
The downside of Brittany
is what she brings
when she goes to a meeting.
It's obviously
putting people off.
J.: It's the first time ever
in the history of Top Model
that no one
wanted to book a girl.
TYRA: The designers
didn't like her walk
or her personality.
NIGEL: You know, I think
Brittany is the perfect example
of what we're always talking
about in this competition,
that you can have almost
the full package,
but without the personality,
you're not going to get hired.
TYRA: I am just as confused
as all of you.
- TWIGGY: Mmm.
- Because no matter how great
you are and no matter
how beautiful your pictures are,
if you don't get the job,
you don't exist
in the modeling world.
- Jaslene.
- J.: There's something
to be said about this girl,
and I think they should look out
because Jaslene, honey,
is coming for you guys.
She's the opposite of Brittany.
She brings in something
that's warm and lovely,
and she's friendly,
and her photographs
are just sensational.
TYRA: Jaslene proved
that she is versatile.
And that's what this whole week
was about, being versatile.
Being able to please
a lot of different types
of clients,
being able to shoot
for a men's magazine,
a woman's magazine.
Dionne.
TWIGGY: For me this week,
Dionne's photographs
are the weakest.
She's not jumping off the page,
and she should.
And the bottom line is,
after we described to her
that rrr! face,
she gave us three looks,
each one with an angry face.
She's going backwards
with how she's looking.
- TWIGGY: Yeah, me too.
- TYRA: She started off
really just girl
kind of on the street,
and then we give her
that physical
and mental makeover,
how to look like a model.
But now she's gone back
to the mall
with the side swoop of the hair,
taking away the inspiration
that we need to look at her
and see a model.
- Renee.
- PRISCILLA: When she came
in to my agency,
I thought really nice girl,
but very commercial.
When you put these pictures
up on the screen,
you could have knocked me down
with a feather.
She really blew me away.
And good on her.
TYRA: I think Renee
is that girl that could possibly
make the most money
out of all the girls
that we have left,
but I fear that Renee
might always be
a catalogue girl.
I still think
she's got a great future.
We have reached a decision.
It's getting hard
up in here.
( music playing )
TYRA: Five girls
stand before me.
And because
you all did
a photo shoot this week
that involved two photographs,
I only have four sets of photos
in my hands.
The first name
I'm going to call...
Jaslene.
Why are you so happy?
JASLENE: Because
I'm the first one to be called.
TYRA: Yeah,
first one to be called
means strongest this week.
You showed versatility.
You were the challenge winner.
Those clients wanted
to book you.
That's the signs of a top model
in the making.
- Thank you, Tyra.
- You're welcome.
The next name
I'm going to call...
Natasha.
Natasha, you're improving
week to week.
One thing
that you have to work on
is relaxing,
relaxing your neck.
Congratulations.
Thank you, Tyra.
The next name
I'm going to call...
Renee.
Renee, you consistently take
very strong photos,
but this competition
is getting tougher.
You're tending to get softer
and sweeter,
which turns into commercial
and safe.
You have to inspire.
Congratulations.
You're still
in the running towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
Thank you.
Will Dionne and Brittany
please step forward.
( music playing )
TYRA: I only have
two photos in my hands,
and those two photos
are of the same girl.
And I'll only call one name.
The name that I do not call
must immediately
pack your belongings
and go home.
Brittany, you've taken some
of the most
beautiful photographs,
but this week,
you went on go-sees,
and not one
of those clients said
that they would book you.
All the pretty pictures
in the world,
it's great,
but if you can't get hired,
you don't exist
in the modeling industry.
Dionne, your pictures
have been nice,
by far not as strong
as Brittany's.
And this week
I came to understand why.
You have to be coached
so, so, so, so much,
as if this is week one
of America's Next Top Model.
So who goes home?
The girl who needs no coaching,
but seems
they can't book a job,
or the girl that needs
so much coaching,
but the clients here
in Sydney like her.
( music playing )
Dionne.
( somber music playing )
TYRA: Dionne,
this picture by no means
is a strong as Brittany's.
But there's something in you
that the clients saw,
something special.
You have so much beauty
and so much light,
you are so strong...
but sometimes too strong,
so you have to soften that.
Congratulations.
You're still on the running
towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
Thank you.
TYRA: Thanks, Brittany.
TYRA: You have to figure out
what that is,
because you have so much beauty
and so much gorgeous pictures,
but you got to book the job.
You're gonna work on that?
Okay. Say goodbye to them.
BRITTANY: It's okay.
Bye, guys.
BRITTANY: When I get told
that I didn't get booked
for my go-sees, it makes me
just sort of realize
that I have a lot to work on.
I've never been, like,
the emotional person,
and I don't know
what made it come out here.
But it shocked me,
and then I didn't know
how to handle it.
I'm going to miss
the whole experience.
I mean, I'm just happy
that I got it.
There are a lot
of girls out there
that wish they could have
this experience,
and...
it's a great opportunity,
and it's been a lot of fun.
( music playing )
TYRA: Coming up
on America's Next Top Model...
( chanting )
TYRA: The girls embrace
the Aboriginal art
of storytelling.
RENEE: We grew tall
and strong together.
( applause )
TYRA: And when Natasha
gets sick,
the rest of the girls do
some storytelling of their own.
None of this no contact
with the camera thing.
We need to send someone home,
and you guys all know
who I'm talking about.
( music playing )
WOMAN:
♪ It's time to make it hot ♪
♪ You know that we don't stop ♪
♪ And when you get it hot ♪
♪ You got to be on top ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na,
na na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na,
na na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪